now let's have a look at this guy here
I'm gonna let you have a go at this
without my help for a minute but let me
just walk you through it make sure
you're doing the right steps it says
find the area of the region bounded by
gives you a new curve y equals x cubed
minus 8 and then it provides you a few
other boundaries not just the x axis but
this time the y axis is involved as well
so I'm gonna ask you I might give you 60
to 90 seconds remember it doesn't need
to be beautiful it just needs to be
close enough to what it's supposed to
look like so you can identify the right
area and do the next step
identify the integral so here's I'm
going to ask you to do go ahead and
actually do a rough sketch of this and
then as you get to the identify integral
point will then pick up together and
I'll show you how I would have a go at
this so I'm gonna hit pause on me you
have a go for a minute and then we'll
come back together to a look at the
solution what I've drawn for you over
here on the left hand side is this is
what the cubic function generally looks
like this is the rough shape of it right
now if I were graphing y equals x cubed
you look something like this right you
would have the center of the curve
Center inverted commas right there on
the origin but I don't have y equals x
cubed I've got y equals x cubed minus 8
so if you think all the way back to the
beginning of last year when we're
looking at functions and how to graph
functions when they've been shifted you
can see that minus 8 is just gonna bring
this guy down eight units okay so I'm
gonna put this down as negative 8 over
here and what that means is I now can
see quite clearly what's the area or
what is the region rather that's bounded
by this blue curve and the x axis and
the y axis it's going to be this section
in here this is the part that I'm after
ok so you can see part of this is
unnecessary let's get rid of that guy
down there all right
now if this is the part that I'm
interested in I've sketched now I need
to identify an integral so help me out
guys I've got area equals 2 and I'm
going to write an integral here what am
i boundary is going to be is anywhere
you've gone and work them out the lower
boundary is a lot easier than the upper
boundary you don't tell me
thank Sasha I like the question mark at
the MA just to hedge your bets there
okay good yes sir Vaughn
got some confirmation the lower boundary
is zero because I'm starting from here
you can see that's the left-hand part of
my green area at X equal zero and then
you need to work out what this guy is
now that's an x intercept so you're
trying to solve for X cubed minus 8
equals zero so this is X cubed equals 8
so you take the cube root of both sides
and that gives you 2 which to confirm
you Sasha gives us an upper boundary of
2 so fantastic I've got zero to two but
then I want to think about this function
in here X cubed minus 8 DX now I want to
pause here right yes the x-intercept is
when y equals zero that's half solve for
x equals two so well done Abby now what
I've done here is this integral actually
isn't going to give us the right area
because if you look at it closely this
integral is in a particular place we
want you to think back to when we were
looking at properties of definite
integrals right this integral is bounded
between both axes and also the curve but
importantly look at its position look
its location it's beneath the x-axis so
this when I evaluate it is going to give
me not the area it's going to give me
the negative of the area what we call
the signed area okay now if you think
back the question has nothing to do with
positives or negatives
it just says at the top here find the
area right so therefore it's up to us to
sort of identify the fact that in fact
this is not the right integral this is
the right integral so that minus side I
would put in right at the outset and you
know Rahul you suggested should we chuck
in an absolute value now some people
will do this let me go after that whole
deletion some people will put in
absolute values like so there's nothing
wrong with that you will get exactly the
right answer because in this case you're
just going to put a minus sign at the
front to make your negative turn into a
positive now for reason is it going to
become clearer a bit later on I'm going
to encourage you not to put an absolute
value sign but rather to actually
deliberately say I know where the
I can see it from my sketch it's beneath
the x-axis so I'm going to put in a
negative at the front the reason why is
sometimes people put in absolute value
signs basically because because they
don't know what they're doing and
they're like I think things I meant to
be positive just going to put some
object value signs here and hopefully I
get the right answer at the end as
you'll see for some examples we're gonna
get to later that's not always the case
and just throwing absolute value signs
around things it's not just gonna make
the answer turn out correctly it's much
better to know that this is below the
axis and in fact I'm even going to write
that let me move this aside so it's a
bit smaller here there we go to identify
from the sketch that this is an area of
beneath the axis and therefore put a
negative at the front so I'm going to
write a equals negative this integral
since region is beneath the x-axis now
to the civil point of our units before
right can you do you have to write that
and short answer is no you don't have to
write it especially as you get very
familiar and comfortable with this
you'll be like yeah I see that pretty
clearly sometimes the diagram make it
very obvious to you however we're not at
that point yet we're still fairly early
on in this and I think this is a much
clearer communication of why does this
minus sign just you know randomly appear
it's like put come on you know a wild
negative sign up here why is it there
there's a reason for it right so I want
to say the reason that I know because I
want to communicate that clearly
all right so sketch done identify the
integral at this point you've probably
been looking at my working big I know
what to do with this so maybe you guys
can help me catch up I've got the minus
sign out the front I've got an X to the
4 on 4 take away 8x then you've got a 0
and a 2 there minus sign stays out the
front and then I'm going to start
evaluating so I've got 2 to the 4 on 4
minus 8 lots of to take away 0 minus
sign again to the power 4 is 16 so 16 on
4 is going to be 4 take away 8 times 2
is 16 and so I've got a negative 12 on
the inside of the bracket so that's
negative of negative 12 so I'm getting
12 are you getting some confirmation of
people got this answer as well or if you
have different answers can you post it
in the comments for me okay thank you
Eddie wonderful all right I was having a
moment of panic because I know Sarang
posted a different answer earlier so
maybe he was answering something else
so just to me now thank you knock there
I'm going to conclude right the area is
12 units squared okay thanks for dinner
okay yeah good good save Sarang very
very smooth all right so be careful
right the sketch helps you when you
identify the integral this is the place
to say oh okay this is a negative so
therefore I should put a minus sign out
the front to cover that and then we get
to the combine in conclusion stage okay
so a third example here before yeah
we're going to have a go at some
exercises after this need to remember
where I was up to in the lesson this guy
is the most complicated of all three and
we're going to have a go at using that
last step of combination here now
everyone just to your question I thought
we'd only find the area when it's
underneath the code
ah okay good question all right let me
address that before I go to this
question we could only find the area
underneath the curve now we use the the
phrase area under the curve kind of as a
um kind of as a shorthand what we really
mean is the area bounded to an axis so
in this case let's go up to this guy
here right the area bounded to the
x-axis it just so happens is also an
area under the curve but when we get to
this guy here the area bounded to the
axis is not under the curve it's above
the curve right and I know that's a
little bit weird we're gonna dig a bit
further into this later during this
double but the key is that area under
the curve is actually kind of a
shorthand the more technically way
correct way to say it is it's the area
bounded to an axis so that might
actually mean below air
under the curve or it might mean above
as in this case here so wherever the
axis is it's going to go from the curve
to there whether that's up or down